And boom,
we're live.
You're here.
Thanks.
We're not a wolf tee shirt on nonetheless.
Yes.
And do Lawrence,
you know,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
Something I bought it this morning.
It's an after Lakota Indians in the vantage beach,
Venice beach,
Lakota Indians.
They're probably not legit it probably Pakistan or something.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
probably.
But uh,
the symbol
lysis and deliverance but not,
you know,
not physical endurance though I a dead stuff,
but a more a like a believing
you have a very fascinating life,
my friend and you have done some amazing things.
I,
I've been paying attention to you for last couple of months,
uh,
pretty,
pretty intensely.
And leading up to this podcast,
I've been researching you a lot.
And uh,
first of all,
I want to know how did all this get started?
For people who don't know who you are,
you've,
you've accomplished a ton of world records.
You've endured things that most people think may be physically impossible.
You proven their possible,
you've shown that you can alter your immune system on demand.
You can,
you can regulate levels of stress hormones that people thought were and unable
to be controlled by the human mind that we're autonomous.
And you're doing this all like on your own.
I've never heard of anybody else doing this.
First of all,
how did you get started in this and what led you to this?
Yes.
Um,
like Manny probably I was in a solar search and uh,
I visited many a country's traditions,
languages as a terrorist disciplines and l two,
like you,
you know,
karate and Kung Fu and a yoga,
but also the [inaudible],
the Sufi Buddhism,
uh,
all kinds of traditions and disciplines,
but that could not really fulfill me in the depth
he's hurt.
And a day was a Sunday,
I was attracted to cold water.
I don't know why,
but uh,
uh,
because I was seeking out already for years,
you have a charge within you.
You always keep on looking,
searching,
seeking.
And at that moment I felt the attraction and that I know I'm going to go in,
you know,
ice water.
And it only took me,
uh,
30 seconds or one minute it took.
But I felt this is it.
This is able to connect me with the depth of my physiology,
the way nature has mandated to be.
So it felt too good.
I felt connected.
This is not something you were drawn to before?
Not really now.
Yeah,
per accident.
I was more conscious at that moment.
And,
uh,
from there I began to do with every day 17 years old.
I was done.
That's about a 38 to years ago.
And,
uh,
from there I began to do it,
on daily,
uh,
you know,
every day.
And this is in Holland that this is in the Netherlands and an adolescent,
the where it's cold water and water transmits the temperature like 25 times more
than the air.
So,
um,
but I returned the other day and uh,
and the other day because I felt too good,
I felt connected.
And it's all about,
it's all about the connection within which I was looking for the depth,
which I could not find in books.
I read hundreds of books and,
um,
philosophy on religion,
on as a terror disciplines at all kinds of books.
You know,
it's searching,
searching,
searching.
But the answer is not in the hat.
The answer is in the body and the brain together.
And Coldwater triggered this and that from that route,
uh,
the cold water,
at a certain point when you do regularly,
you become coaches.
You breathing pattern is going to change because she got to be more effective.
You need more oxygen to withstand the impact of the cold and that needs oxygen.
It needs compassion in the cell.
And I'm feeling it.
I was doing that and I change my breathing pattern and when I change my
breathing pattern is when the magic began.
Then I began to see,
you know,
lights by manipulating the breathing differently lights like how so?
Yeah,
they got in the yoga,
they call it the Chakras in China,
they call it the key,
the Ci,
Eh,
and uh,
and so forth.
And uh,
I found out,
uh,
that this was very possible in a very short period of time.
And this is nothing someone's showed you how to do.
This is something you figured out on your own.
The cold is my only mastered the cold is my only teacher in the breeding police.
Say you altered your breathing patterns.
Like what do you mean exactly?
Like,
uh,
when I went in at a certain point I knew how to be,
you know,
very relaxed.
Go,
went in,
then latec a cold car,
impact a go within and then begin breathing deeper and then a certain dance
between the cold and to breathe.
A breath begins to start up,
begins to charge.
He bought it.
And after 25 breaths,
like that,
very conscious in the cold,
the cold is a forest and it has this impact and you go along with a cold and
what it does in the Phasia on the physiology and you use your breathing.
Now I know what happens.
Visual Latika but then those days it was all by feeling and after what does
happen physiologically or you become a fully charged,
eh,
the,
the carbon dioxide goes out,
eh,
oh to begins to roam freely throughout the body and the fields up.
Every cell and the Ph levels go up.
Now when you,
when you say you altered your breathing,
we,
what you're showing me here,
it's just breathing in and breathing out.
Like what is split specifically different about that than normal breathing?
The way I used it,
um,
W it was like after 25 breaths,
Eh,
it was so fully charged,
I could stay like five to seven minutes under the ice every time,
very controlled.
And that means that there is not only a whole lot of oxygen inside the body and
the,
but the Ph levels go up.
Now there's,
uh,
later on I began to understand by signs,
by,
by thinking about it,
and then,
uh,
I deducting and all that I,
I saw that,
uh,
that we are able to tap into the brainstem,
the adrenaline we showed lying in bad people,
a pure producing more adrenalin.
Now I know how to show to people just in a couple of days.
That means every listener right now is able to do that.
So we have proven this scientifically and it showed that people lying in bed
were able to produce more adrenaline than somebody in fear going for its first
punky jump,
bungee jump and when,
but you're still,
I'm still confused as to how you're,
you're doing anything differently other than deep breathing.
You're taking a deep breathe in,
deep breathe out.
And now we retent from breathing after exhalation read tent.
Uh,
we stopped breathing after acceleration once.
Breathe in like,
well,
show me the method.
Like if,
if you,
if you go with me at 30 times,
okay,
go.
Okay,
boolean.
We're once again fully in.
Go
right on fully and but Latin girl.
Hm.
Not fully out.
Just letting your but fully.
And
once again,
I wanted to again,
come up,
don't hesitate.
Give it.
It's about changing the chemistry right now in your body.
So I'm going to become lightheaded and at a certain point you're so fully
charged and ph levels go to a very high level.
You're able to stay without eh,
in the long four minutes.
Jess,
keep on that feeling is understanding.
Go on and deeply yet letting go deeply yet letting go deeply in Ladd and go 10
times more deeply than that.
Didn't go deeply in letting go.
I'm going to time.
It didn't go deeply and daddy go gave it fully.
Take him in,
let him go to air command Ladd and go take him in letting go.
No agitation.
I do this with the ovary and Matt as well and he feels wonderful.
Thank man.
Who are they?
Letting go.
Okay,
five times more deeply and letting go.
Letting go deeply and let it go two times more.
Letting go and stop
just top witness without and the lungs.
You are able to stay much more than normally that normally.
Why?
Because we change.
He'll chemistry.
Carbon dioxide went out,
oh two went up,
failed top oldest towels and the Ph levels go up.
Then we are able to tap into their central nervous system and at the end that we
got the brain stamp and that's the place of the pineal gland.
Hypothalamus,
pituitary gland and the pineal gland makes the secretion of Adrenalin in
dangerous situations.
Normally we do not get into it because of of our shallow breathing,
but this is the way to get into the most primitive part of the reptilian brain
without many difficulties and fend off bacteria getting better into the
endocrine systems.
We talk about it later.
Your pastor one one 10 in minutes and you're still on.
They chose that the capacity to fill yourself up with oxygen,
there's a lot more than we normally use and as we do not use it,
we are not making use of the full capacity of our faith physiology.
Now we found out we got a different layers and we never use it and this is the
way to learn to use it to tap in and bang into the primitive brain,
into the endocrine systems,
immune systems,
the way nature has mandate to be.
Everybody is able to do one 45 and this is only ranked one if it would do like
three rounds,
you would go to three minutes,
four
minutes without air,
without training.
It only shows the capacity to store up oxygen
inside.
We never use that.
You're doing great.
And is he is doing already to two,
five almost to 10 whenever you feel the urge to breathe,
you don't need to.
Force is only learning how to access,
energize the body and older cells.
You're going Greg,
man,
now he's a field.
Good,
Huh?
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
That's okay.
Two 30 Oh
yeah.
When you feel the urge to breathe,
you breathe in fully and keep it for 10 15 seconds.
That's one fully year.
And keep it and I will you press your belly,
the neck and then the hat
and now you are able to tap into the brainstem.
Yeah,
that's him.
If we would do it again,
you would,
you know,
it was very light headed,
breathing the breathing in part.
So w w two to explain to people at home what I'm doing is I'm breathing in all
the ways is deeply as I can,
but I'm not breathing out all the way.
Yeah.
I'm just breathing out a little bit and then I'm breathing in more and I'm just
breathing out a little bit and I'm breathing in more and breathing out a little
bit.
Yes.
And if you breathe,
breathe,
and completely,
you got all the oxygen possible and it's hot.
If you just a go,
then you get a two,
uh,
where the exchange of the gasses happen.
And this is the way a bass to energize the body.
So it's a different way to get into the chemistry of the body.
We have shown this,
not you.
That's one of the fascinating things.
If,
if people are listening to this guy,
this guy's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
definitely a crazy,
crazy,
beautiful,
beautiful way.
I know,
I know.
What you've done is you've allowed scientists to test you every step of the way
and you've proven that all this is true when we're saying these things.
I mean,
this is,
these are things that have been studied at universities.
What was the university in Holland that bow,
a university crowd bowed and they injected you with an endotoxin.
Endotoxin.
Yeah.
To prove that you can,
you can autoregulate your immune system.
Exactly.
Uh,
normally it has a,
it's a controlled experiment and they did it with thousands of people already
and nobody was able to control a,
to the depth of the immune system because the endotoxin provokes a response and
the immune system,
you,
you become feverish.
You get headaches all over agony,
uncontrolled vomiting,
uh,
in are things like that happen.
But,
uh,
the,
the people I trained first,
I did it myself and then they said,
yeah,
but you are the ice man.
You are an exception on the roof.
Are you confirmed the rule because of this?
Now I said,
anybody can do this.
Why would they say that?
You confirm the rule.
If they have a rule and one person can do something different,
then the rule doesn't work.
It's not a rule anymore.
It is.
That's absolutely true between us.
But in science it only works.
It's only validated if it is a group who's doing it right.
But how many in the group are doing your method?
That's the thing.
When,
when when they test normal people on things,
did the amount of people that are doing what you're doing and trying these kind
of experiments and going under ice and breathing and you're breathing.
It's almost none worldwide.
I mean I'm sure more people now are inspired to do it because of you,
but so I don't understand how they could say that you confirm the rule because
you don't,
uh,
he,
you know,
you don't,
it doesn't apply to you.
Yeah.
At that's the saying,
you know,
it take acception confirms the rule.
That's a Dutch say.
So I told him,
yes,
I'm the eyes man.
I got so much a experience.
I did so many challenges and records,
but no,
the paying it,
my mission is to show to everybody is able to tap in there physiology a lot
deeper just in a couple of days and it has been shown 12 people in a comparative
study,
12 people been instructed and 12 people,
none as directed.
The non had instructed people are got to be sick,
all of them and the instructed people,
all of them were not sick.
Now this endotoxin would exactly is the endotoxin that endotoxin is a,
uh,
is a part of a bacteria and the immune system recognizes it as a,
as an,
uh,
a negative intruder.
So,
uh,
that's why it is a controlled experiment and,
there's the way they inject it and they try to learn about immune system,
the endocrine systems by doing this controlled experiments on many,
many people all over the world.
Now,
prior to doing this,
what made you think that you could do this?
Like what,
what,
what convinced you that you could actually regulate your immune system to react
to response?
It was injected into your body like that.
Now you're not,
now you're talking to now we begin to talk like 25 years ago already stated and
told everybody the autonomous nervous system and the immune systems related to
the atomic nervous system can be influenced.
Uh,
the autonomic nervous system will be no log autonomy at a,
at just what I told,
uh,
many people mark meet because of it.
And they told me negatively that I was crazy and all that.
Which see,
25 years
ago you were in your twenties,
then I,
yeah,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Tell her thirties.
Okay.
And that will be now 56.
So,
uh,
yeah,
56.
Um,
but that I,
I told her then and now it's scientifically proven,
Eh,
uh,
yeah.
It's uh,
why,
uh,
because I inside,
I know.
So you're this 31 year old guy and you have this,
this idea in your head that you can control your,
your,
your immune system.
Yes.
What,
what gave you this thought that you could do this?
I know in the beginning when I was 17 years old,
as the story began,
I went into the cold and I,
it just felt good.
It felt,
I felt connection.
After years of searching,
I as a day you have a certain kind of knowledge,
you know,
but from the inside altered the gut feeling and intuition and that's more than
the,
uh,
what we think,
and this is not a reaction to how your body felt when you got out of the water.
Like you're saying,
Ooh,
I've,
I feel like I get less sick.
I feel like I'm healthier.
Oh,
he's just,
there was that too.
Yes.
But it was also you,
you felt internally that you were controlling it,
like you could feel it.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
You get a real sense.
There's say you are a fighter pilot example,
you got to opponent,
but this time the opponent is yourself.
Mm.
And uh,
and you know it from the inside and you feel it from the inside and it makes you
happy.
It makes you strong and makes you healthy.
And this is what we have lost from nature and now it's back.
So,
so in a sense,
what you've done is you tapped into something extremely primal by dealing with
one of the most primal elements at all of all which is cold.
Yes.
So the cold,
like the,
in the vice documentary,
I thought it was really fascinating.
You said cold is your God.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
If I had a teach at,
I've never had a teacher that's uh,
that's amazing.
I know.
Goudreau or mentor or Sifu or anything like that.
The cold,
that's my teacher.
That's my God.
I've been dodging the colts and tells a little kid.
It's amazing.
You just felt compelled to jump into that.
Yes.
I feel good when you're saying this to people when you're 31 years old and
you're telling people I can control my immune system,
they,
they have been like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Look at this guys jumping in the freezing water and he says he can controls
immune system.
How did you convince people to the point that you got actual scientists to
measure your blood?
Do legitimate scientific studies on you?
Like what was it your accomplishments like you went for people who don't know
you,
you did a bunch of really unbelievable tasks.
You climbed Everest in your,
did you have shoes on when you climbed Everest?
Yes,
I had to with spikes spikes,
ice climbing right at [inaudible].
No showed on
that.
I think I go buy clothes.
It's insane because it's like you are not challenging,
uh,
nature you can go up with,
with their car as well and then you go up Everest,
right?
Anything artificial you use in nature doesn't make you having the right
connection with nature.
And what I wanted to challenge in all the challenges I did like marathons beyond
the polar circle in midwinter in short,
but also in the heat of the desert without drinking or hanging by one finger on,
I want to have Columbia like a mile up in the air.
What in winter time you hung up by one finger.
A mile up in the air.
Yes.
Where was this alternate Holland.
Her between two hot air balloons and then climbing between them.
And then there was a,
you know,
a thing,
a device I could have looked it on with one finger.
Yes.
How long has your hang there for a 25 seconds.
Jesus Christ.
Five seconds.
And with one finger in wintertime,
winter time,
you know you lose control when the blood becomes cold or into hands,
you lose control.
So that was the challenge.
It's mind over matter.
And I wanted to show that in all the challenges,
the adaptive power of ours is enormous.
But as we are not stimulating or using that anymore,
you got a neglected body and become sick or half [inaudible] in its potency.
And so very logic.
So the powers that our body has,
the untapped powers that we probably had for millennia,
dealing with the cold,
dealing with the heat,
dealing with adversity,
dealing with struggle,
all those powers are not being tapped into.
So because of that,
the body just atrophies and we don't,
it doesn't know what to do with yourself.
Exactly.
You,
you think that that may be also a cause of depression?
Yes.
I'm a right now into new research.
Uh,
as soon as I,
I wa I want to do research.
Uh,
they did research on mindfulness power example,
mindfulness,
uh,
related to depression.
And um,
I think not only me,
all two psychiatrists,
they saw the blood values,
the markers in the blood within the hour study and most probably our method,
this what we just did brings the people very much faster into controlling their
endocrine system.
The endocrine system is about hormonal,
uh,
balances in the body and about,
because we are not able to tap into that and we are victimized because of too
much stress or this or the daily life or whatever.
And we get depressed and we are not able to get out of it.
Now this method because of tapping into the endocrine systems,
makes you feel you are able to re balance the hormonal,
this disturbance in the body,
creating,
uh,
eventually,
in length,
uh,
the,
the depression.
So I want research on this because this is,
my wife died in [inaudible] 95 because of suicide.
I have four children were with her,
I was powerless then my heart was broken and uh,
had no money,
no nothing.
And then they struggle.
And this fight began.
I'm going to prove this to the world and uh,
and create a shortcut for anybody who is depressed or you know,
sick and everything.
And now we got to key,
we cut key to the endocrine systems and the immune systems and anybody can do
this.
And because it is done by science,
it's beyond speculation.
We make it a choice.
And that's why I'm on a mission.
And this mission breaks me here to Joe Rogan,
who's a good guy.
He's a fighter himself and he loves life and he brings it out and he tries
people out.
I can see,
I can tell and I people out.
Yeah,
yeah.
Try it.
People,
uh,
who are you?
What are you doing?
And things like that.
It's a a,
I like it.
I love it.
And we need to do this because we got to change this world where there is no
control.
I mean we can build,
we can fly to the moon,
we can make,
this is more intelligence than the whole Apollo 13 project.
Yes.
If we can,
this is the fruit of our mind and that the power of our mind is enormous,
but now it is time to use the same power to learn to control our happiness,
strength and health.
And we have shown this now.
So you feel like
the,
the what happened with your wife that your,
your wife killed herself was due to depression and you feel like that that type
of depression,
the depression that a lot of people experience is because their mind is not
stimulated the way it was intended to by nature.
Is that a fair way of describing your,
your thoughts on this?
Absolutely.
And that we're left with a residual effect of civilization in a way where your
mind is,
it's overwhelmed with things that really are not natural.
Like living in a cubicle distress of office life traffic,
things that aren't natural.
Exactly.
We are living to work their system.
It be going around,
right?
The system once again,
shoot,
serve our happiness,
strength and health.
And now we have proof that we are able to tap in to the endocrine systems and
the immune system far deeper.
So we got to try this and it is natural.
Anybody can do this in just a couple of days.
Right now we are in the third year of the university books here in America.
The,
the testing,
the iceman.
It's not about me anymore.
It's about the comparative study.
Uh,
and then it tells the endocrine systems and they immune systems and it only
takes one guy is endurance.
You know,
believe that we are able to tap in deeper into our fish physiology.
Does a bling enabling the person to,
uh,
to direct his hormonal secretions.
Strength per example,
lying in bed as we told already,
producing,
lying in bed.
There's no rhinoceros coming to that guy.
Now he's at ease and he controls completely the stress hormone and the
controlled stress amone works like medicine and non controlled stress hormone
works in the end acidic and that becomes no good.
And that's,
we are victimized because we have no control in daily life anymore.
But the stress is there.
So the stress is there,
but there's no physical exertion.
Yes.
And that's why they've shown tasks that in many cases,
um,
exercise can be just as good as antidepressants,
just as good as medication for people who are depressed.
W which totally makes sense if what you're saying is right,
that it totally makes sense that your,
your body like has a desire to exert itself.
And it has a built in system that's designed to deal with certain natural
stresses running from predators,
dealing with the cold and dealing with weather and climate and,
and nature and the adversities of the environment as far as like a challenging
yourself,
climbing hills and exerting yourself,
we don't do that that much.
And because of that,
that's what you think leads to this,
this disease of the brain.
Yes.
And you know,
for many people who are depressed,
they are quite unable to get into that body and begin to run and things like
that.
Eh,
it's a,
it's the brain and where we are going to solve this by very easy techniques.
A instead of them having to run because they are,
our environment is really pressing upon them.
They feel completely immobilized.
But if you are able to tap into with the brain and lot to make,
feel the change that he is changing the,
the,
the chemistry of the brain,
then it becomes a different person,
uh,
a much faster.
So,
um,
but uh,
yeah,
I'm a subject to science and I want more research on this and soon it we have
the outcomes and then we will tackle this problem with the depression because
it's related to the endocrine systems and having no connection with it.
Normally the hypothalamus in a,
our,
uh,
primitive brain,
the brainstem is not under our control,
but the idea is breathing techniques deriving from being in the cold so much.
They are very effective,
not only in the Colt,
which is stress,
but also in the heat ultra for a predator.
Also on Mount Everest where there is a lack,
a lack of oxygen outset and also for daily stress.
What was the first one of these experiments that you tried to do to try to show
the effectiveness of your methods day?
I was at a physiological department in the same university,
different department,
and that's a cult physiological department.
And I still there for 80 minutes in a tank full of ice for 18 minutes,
fully connected to wires being,
uh,
blood was taken.
So you just covered in ice cover deniers,
pictures of it.
It looks insane.
[inaudible]
except for this arm I,
because the blood was taken away from it.
Um,
and they,
you know,
what they saw and I was talking to these people,
Eh,
to these professors who were,
well,
everything was because I was very much in control and they saw the core
temperature either rising while it was insight in a core temperature was rising
while you're covered in ice for 80.
Yes.
And you see how much power we have,
how much,
you know,
how much power coal can be and,
but how much more power we are able to learn to control.
And,
and that the blood taken from me while I was in the tank,
I got a few remarkable results,
eh,
uh,
one s the blood taken,
it was exposed to endotoxin afterwards,
but in a laboratory without me ex vivo,
it's called.
And they saw,
normally it has a very,
uh,
violent reaction on the immune cells in the,
in the,
in the glass of the,
you know,
the laboratory.
And this time,
0%,
a hundred percent suppression.
And that's my blood a hundred percent,
hundred percent.
So the endotoxin just get squashed the moment he gets in there.
And that's the bacteria.
Yeah.
And that's the immune system.
And that's the way we actually built a,
to be able to,
and uh,
that was one where way,
and now that I'm,
a remarkable thing,
before I was going into the tank,
they took blood from me as well.
And Eh,
this blood was
looked upon,
intuit my by a microscope.
And they saw a 300% more metabolic activity in the cell without moving.
That's the mind my mind was already into.
I go inside that one in the box,
I need to do 80 minutes.
I program my on up till cell level.
What I'm about to do,
I need more energy because energy is needed to with Stan,
the impact of the cold.
So I control my buddy by my mind and that's all of us.
And this mine then makes the connection with the Hypothalamus,
which is the brainstem.
And that is able to control the,
the hormonal system,
the immune systems,
the vascular system,
all the systems.
Now when you say that your metabolic rate rose 300% is not a normal thing
because of the cold,
because that's one thing that they tell you that it's a great way to lose
calories.
Just dress very lightly when it's cold outside.
Yes.
And it forces your body to work hard,
to stay warm.
So it,
it was an effective that.
Yeah.
Uh,
it was,
it was at,
that's a ultra a thing about the brown fat adipose,
Eh,
we got all these sales,
but as we never exposed to cold anymore,
it doesn't,
uh,
it's not stimulated is like a muscle.
You,
you're new to a train,
it becomes weaker.
So we got old to alter the cells which needs stimulation.
I did experiments with a brown fat adipose and the,
and the nuclear,
uh,
department of nuclear,
medical,
uh,
department in Maastricht,
a different university.
And it showed that I had the same brown fat adipose levels as a young man,
like 20 years,
15 years.
They still have it,
but you get older,
you wear clothes and that you get a,
you lose it.
It's logical.
But I always a expose myself to cold on a regular basis.
So they had me expos as well too,
in an experiment like that.
And they saw that I with the same level of,
or amount of adipose tissue,
brown fat adipose cells,
I could produce five time more,
uh,
more energy.
That's what they saw.
So compared to these guys,
because of the breathing and influencing into on cell level,
I was able to do five times more and this could be a solution.
People
who have overweigh because when the fat is consumed,
Eh,
and which is very,
um,
in the moment when you need it,
then a gets depleted.
Then,
uh,
the rest of the,
the,
the white fat in the body is being withdrawn very systematically,
very effectively,
direct and,
but like five times more effective.
It's maybe a solution for many people living in the,
in the west with,
you know,
obese problems and heart problems because vascular problems because of it,
et cetera.
There's a,
a,
a type of therapy that's becoming really popular here in America called
cryotherapy.
A lot of athletes use it and I started using it a few years ago.
Um,
a lot of people from Jujitsu were telling me about this thing when you go is
stay in this,
it's a box.
It's 250 degrees below zero when you do three minutes in it.
Yeah,
I do it four days a week now.
It's,
it's amazing.
It's nice.
It's amazing.
I,
I get out of there,
I feel so great.
And I had my friend,
doctor,
Rhonda Patrick,
who's a scientist and she explained all the,
what's happening inside of it.
And then I took her to the,
to the,
to the chamber and had her stand in the,
uh,
the cryo chamber and she,
she said it was incredible when she got out of it,
but seeing she was a scientist,
she understands the body very well.
So she knew that there was,
it was raising her levels of neoprene,
Afrin and her whole body was being stimulated by this reaction to this extreme
250 degree below zero cold.
Yes,
I did at that too.
And uh,
uh,
yeah.
Uh,
have you done the one where you get inside of it but fully or the one that's
just from the not fully and uh,
and uh,
up til the neck a couple of times and uh,
yeah,
I could stay a quite long and the like,
it's staying there forever.
I won't go in there for,
I don't know why my bay 10 minutes or something and,
but they're still feeling okay.
I didn't,
yeah,
three minutes,
three minutes and 30 seconds.
And I do it more than anybody in the whole place.
I can't believe you get deterred by this.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a thing.
We're with a nature.
Keep going and keep going and then you just push your boundaries.
That's it.
But it is not necessary to uh,
reestablish the right natural connection between your brain and your endocrine
systems and immune systems.
Just a little bit of cold is enough to trigger the vascular system the right
way,
enabling it,
uh,
to work better with their nervous system and then the breathing and focus your
mind like the mind was able without moving to produce 300% more metabolic
activity in the cell that is mine.
That the mind is so much able to do so much more.
And this is the quintessential,
this is the essence of what I come to tell you.
We got to change how I believe we got to change
the way we think.
It's a like a paradigm shift and a why because we have proven with thousands and
thousands of results beyond speculation that we are able,
if we use our mind once again,
that not in dependency for doctors and this and that and [inaudible] no,
you are able to repair yourself whenever you feel not healthy or depressed or
uh,
w with a loss of energy,
you know,
Eh,
strength,
happiness and to health,
then you should go in and breathe better and that you will reestablish the
connection,
uh,
with the endocrine system,
say immune systems and the brain together and then repair whatever is producing
an obstacle for you to function in the world.
Maybe you are able to function in the world,
but you don't feel good.
You don't feel uh,
happy and a,
you don't feel strong.
So tell say if a person had a cold,
slight cold,
what would you recommend they do?
I would say breathing once,
breeding your method,
your breathing fully is hard and deep as you can.
And then just actually a little bit breathe in as far as your lung to stretch.
How many likes?
I like 20 times,
20 times.
Dan,
take him in and then go to the place to the spot where you feel the cold is
happening.
Could be in the throat,
could be eh,
could be,
you know,
somewhere in the,
at this part.
So go in your mind to that spot.
You know what happens when I'm in the ice for an hour,
for example.
Most of the Times I began to feel it,
the cold,
Eh,
at the part of the kidneys,
which is a mostly on the,
on,
on the surface,
and the cold gets there,
the eyes,
then I ain't got no,
there is no way I'm able to move because it's like six,
700 kilos of ice around me
and I'm not able even to breathe very much because it's pressurizing.
What I learned is to think it a way,
within a minute,
I made a difference from the brain to the kidneys and change the temperature
like 10 degrees.
This is a measurable thing.
You've changed a measurable 10 degrees.
Eh,
Dr Ken Karma who did experiments with me,
I did records a year in New York and Florida.
I don't know,
it's a couple of places.
And while I was in the show,
for example,
Regis and Kelly show,
you know the guys,
right?
And uh,
an Isa,
my core temperature was dropping,
was dropped to 30 to a degree Celsius,
Celsius.
I don't know why,
but it is far low.
Way Low.
Eh,
people are not a normally not able to raise the temperatures anymore.
They just go into
unconsciousness and coma and things like that.
But I rose the temperature back and he said he had never had seen a person do
that because facial logically stated in the signs of books,
it's not possible.
And I say,
you know,
so much more is possible than not only a,
connecting with your core temperature but also with the endocrine system.
So when you say you were raising your temperature,
where w what was the environment that you were raising your temperature in,
where you were in the water while this was happening in the tank,
the ice freezing cold and you raise your temperature from there.
Yes.
That's amazing.
No,
what we are able to do.
That's amazing.
Life is amazing.
Her,
Wanda,
and we have to reexperience that and that's the paradigm shift.
We are able to learn to control.
It needs some steady attention like a baby needs attention to grow up.
We need to pay attention to ourselves again,
trust ourselves.
Again,
belief,
believing is neurotransmitters in the right way and when it connects with the
body again and we got the techniques and it does have been shown with thousands
of results that we are able to control the endocrine systems or a better set,
eh,
our mood becoming happy,
yes or no.
Serotonin,
Melatonin,
dematerial trip to mine and all the Yada,
our amounts,
we are able to tap into that system.
We have shown that another one,
the strength,
which is adrenaline,
epinephrine,
norepinephrine,
noradrenaline or accord is all and all that.
We have shown more than somebody lying in bed.
Then somebody going into a bank of jam that's tracked and then health.
It's the immune system's learning to tap into the immune systems and like cry
with therapy as you were talking,
mentioning it goes on to up till the bone marrow.
It activates these blood markers over there and people with arthritis then are
able to move a barrier again after a session like that,
but we were these breathing techniques.
We get into the bone marrow as well and there we have the t cells,
the t cells and the bees out and they are a part of the specific immune system
and the specific immune system normally only begins to work after two weeks and
then the body knows what kind of molecules it needs to produce to kill the SA,
the intruder cell and it gets on the membrane,
the skin of the cell and it killed it instead of inflammatory [inaudible].
The older body,
it goes very specifically,
but it takes two weeks.
We do with a one quarter of an hour with this breathing and only with his
breathing,
you are able to control the Ph level and the Ph level,
right as we are mammals,
if you look in nature,
you see all these mammals.
If you take blood from them,
they all have the right Ph degree.
Very alkaline and but only because we were close and we are live in a comfort
zone.
We do not stimulate.
That's oxygen doesn't get as deep as it could.
You have shown this two and a half minutes without air in the lungs.
That means the capacity to store up oxygen is far bigger than you normally use.
But it's still pretty minor though,
right?
Like what you,
you held your breath for seven minutes.
Is that what you did?
Yes.
And under the eyes and but that once again that,
that,
that what day to do you have been fighting paypal?
I have a good winner because I was not trained to do that.
You have trained to do that.
I trained to do this,
that,
that but that's the range of possibilities.
But Eh,
it's very unimportant.
We don't need to know,
hey rose,
we knew it needed to become healthy,
strong and happy.
Does it matter whether you breathe in through your nose or in through your
mouth?
Cause there's a big thing in yoga and they teach you that in a lot of other
[inaudible] too.
They try to teach you to breathe in through your nose.
I wrote books on the subject before.
Now I say,
doesn't matter what county are your whole year use?
Just get it in
girls and these women and ask her.
I just tell them that to make a joke,
but it is a serious thing as we got it scientifically endorsed,
no speculation.
Just do.
It just is easy,
accessible,
very effective because the idea is when you breathe in through your mouth,
they Burberry induces panic breathing.
That's what they say in in Jujitsu.
That does to keep yourself calm.
You're supposed to,
you breathe in through your nose and out through your mouth,
in through your nose and out through your mouth and then yoga,
they tried to teach you to do the entire class through your nose.
Yeah.
I don't think it matters.
Now it doesn't matter a row and I'm going to tell him that tomorrow.
Yeah,
test do it.
In this technique,
which has been shown as the first group in the world to be able to tap into the
autonomic nervous system related to the immune system and endocrine system.
It shows the depth and,
and this depth normally as a result maybe
of Yogis who are really going into summaries and Dharana and,
and a into the Kundalini up to the Sahasrara and all that.
The,
the,
the comeback.
I yogi and I know all this,
all the terminology I've been doing since creed in India and uh,
before,
but,
uh,
I thought to be far too complicated.
They,
they,
Eh,
you know,
they made it into a myth.
We Westerners,
we have no time.
We want to understand things the way we are a living.
And I thought to simplify it and uh,
science,
uh,
backed it up.
Now when you talking about your breathing,
you were saying that when you were young that you,
when you discovered this type of breathing that you could see lights.
Yes.
You know,
Dan is,
that's one of the core components of Kundalini Yoga.
The chakras.
Yeah.
That they experience this intense state due to this specific type of re I don't
have a presence.
There's this is a done nervous system.
I could make you do they say in a 15 minutes and what do you but what is that?
Is it just your body's production of the nervous system?
The nervous system is about electrical potentials.
Just firing.
That's it.
You're just manipulating the nervous system,
pressurizing her and then uh,
electricity comes out a bigger,
so what you were saying before about someone who has a cold,
so you would tell them to utilize your breathing method and concentrate on the
area in which they're sick.
Like if they have a lung infection,
concentrate on clearing the lung,
any infection,
any disease,
any,
anything they got,
we have the ability to connect with our body.
You just have to absolutely believe it and you have to absolutely be focused on
if you are,
if you want to phone then if I want my phone then I need to grab this one.
Not this one,
not this one.
And not that I have to be busy with what I'm doing for grab the actual phone.
I got it.
Go to the place where something is happening.
So if there is a disturbance,
she go to the to step until you release it.
You got it.
Learn to connect.
Once again,
that's the change of the believe they changed the of the believers.
Not nothing more than the the mind which is neurotransmitter's electrical
potentials and use it once again instead of being alienated because of conflict
behavior,
you learn to use these neuro macro bola biological patterns again,
which are,
which are existent,
but they are an a down exercise unexercised and that's why we,
we don't trust them because they are not so strong.
Learn that these are very capable of you
making connection with the endocrine systems,
immune systems far deeper,
thus being able to control happiness,
health and strength.
And we are going to prove this more and more because um,
uh,
dealing with,
universities and I want to,
I want cold measurements,
figures,
statistics,
no speculation.
Well that's what separates you from a lot of people who've made these crazy
claims.
You've actually done physical feats that show extraordinary abilities.
What,
what you did in Mt.
Everest.
No one's ever done before.
And I've never even heard of anybody attempting to do something like that.
You ran a marathon,
half marathon in Finland.
We did you run a barefoot?
Yes.
Above.
I mean you were,
you were,
how cold was it out?
It was like minus 30 outside.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She's duty.
Reach about those.
Definitely a shirtless,
right?
Yeah.
Just shorts,
shirt,
shorts,
barefoot.
You run a half mile at minus 30 so that's what this is that 15 miles.
13 miles.
Yeah.
It was something.
What's up there?
But that's undeniable.
That's undeniable.
So when,
when people,
is that why you started doing these things so that people would pay attention to
what you're doing?
Because when,
when you hear someone doing that,
when you hear someone's climbing mount Everest and their shorts,
you go,
what?
Okay,
what is he doing?
How's he doing that?
And then when you find out you're incredibly healthy and you're vibrant and
you're doing all these things and you,
you're allowing yourself to be tested and you're showing this ability to
regulate your immune system.
And this is all incredibly exciting stuff.
And then the scientists come in because then they're like,
okay,
what is going on here?
And we have to change our beliefs about what is possible with the humans.
Exactly.
And be very clear about it.
No speculation.
It all began with a,
you know,
well,
and I felt so powerless with her,
my wife then those days I loved her to death,
but not in that way.
Of course,
I work now with the four children I have with her.
I had with her,
I still have with her.
And uh,
I began to,
I only could find rest and peace within the depth of my own
being emotionally,
you know,
you cannot see it,
but it is there.
And uh,
for that I went into nature.
I began to climb without gear and go into the eyes more.
And this made me silent within that horse,
my Keurig,
it calmed your all the horrible stress and depression.
Emotion is stress.
And uh,
later on I began to understand about it,
but then I caught the attention of the news and then,
uh,
they began to ask,
but are you able to do this then too?
And I able to do,
I told them,
oh yeah,
I can do that.
I can swim under the ice like this and says,
oh yeah,
I can climb the mountain barefoot in the snow.
Yeah.
I can hang by
one finger in the air.
Yeah.
I can't run a marathon.
A is SharePlus,
uh,
beyond the polar circle.
Midwinter I can do all this.
And then science came in,
they came into the newspapers and the Internet and all that and they took,
how is this possible?
This is where the,
did they not believe you at first?
Of course if somebody,
it tells in the books and the university books now,
which have been dedicating one chapter about the ice man,
which is the study which we did,
that you see the old story that w where professors normally they say,
yeah,
this is not possible in the,
in the books it stated it is not possible to do a half marathon barefoot or
climbing mount Everest that way because of the physiology of hours and,
and the hardships outside.
It's not possible,
but this guy is doing it.
So,
oh,
so began to raise questions and then they invited me to be tested and they were
skeptical.
They were absolutely skeptical or only won't clinical proof of what I was doing,
which surpassed the official logical laws stated in the,
in the books.
If I was able to produce that in laboratory settings.
And then they had a,
you know,
something to start off with to do at a,
which could be a possible method or a abilities,
uh,
evidence based,
helping people who are sick.
And now we are going to do more clinical studies.
Show is sick people to be able to cure a lot faster or not to uh,
having,
uh,
to make use of as much medicine as they do now because yeah,
I'm a,
I'm not anti uh,
pharmaceutics or anything lighter because I'm not into politics but I'm a in a,
you know,
I want people to know there is so much more within every person here in the
world which will enable you to tackle a disease unhappiness and having no energy
or strength and uh,
we are able to do that and that's love.
I want to bring back love in the world constituted by happiness,
strength and health.
It's just fascinating that it takes you,
you're such an outlier there.
It took one person to come up with this method and one person to challenge these
ideas that the body can't do this and now they have to reconsider this 7 billion
people on the planet.
We've been around for who knows how long we've thousands of years of written
history and then they had these laws that they believed that the body was
capable of doing and not capable of doing.
This is,
this is where
it ends that you body can't do this,
your body can't do that.
And you came along,
one guy,
Wim Hoff,
you come along and you change everything.
That's amazing.
That's,
that's truly,
truly amazing.
It's amazing.
You know,
it's,
uh,
I wasn't ever out there to,
to,
to change the world,
but because of,
you know,
things happened in my life,
I triggered,
it was triggered in the depth of my body and even in the emotional part as I
explained before,
because of my wife and all that,
and now I'm very,
very certain.
I got a mission.
It was born in 2007 in the Feinstein Institute,
Manhasset New York.
When doctor Carol,
I've,
Kevin Carr,
Carmilla,
uh,
gave me the results of a blood result after an experiment in the Feinstein
Institute,
which is a biochemical institute.
And he told me,
if you are able to reproduce these results and pass it on to a group of persons,
say in two weeks,
then that would mean huge consequences for human mankind.
Then I did the,
the missionary was born,
my mission was born.
And since then I want to get into it and beyond speculation,
prove it by evidence and it is believe emotion,
uh,
and believe are very close together.
We lost the emotion,
we lost a feeling,
the,
the sensitivity and we lost the belief within ourselves.
And we got to go back to the belief.
Believe as able to tackle science,
believe is able to tackle any problem into a,
in life by every person.
And uh,
believe is chemistry.
And we have to go back to that chemistry and we are showing this insight by
scientific,
uh,
evidence and a result.
I think what you're doing is so important.
It's so important to,
to human beings.
Because we were existing,
we were operating under a false assumption and this false assumption had made it
into textbooks.
And we,
for a guy like you comes along and shows a method for changing,
changing your physiology.
And if you could teach that to children early on,
he would change their operating paradigm.
You change the way their mind views the world.
You would change.
It would change our them at Joe,
Joe Rogan's.
Alright.
Pleasure.
Handshake shirt.
Now I understand why you can hang by one finger.
I will.
What does that feeling like,
man,
when you're hanging a mile in the air by one finger,
what does that feel on?
Like,
I felt great.
You know,
all the,
all the things that I do,
I never know what before I'm doing it.
So you never know what it's gonna feel like.
Yeah.
What's going to chill.
Act is hanging from your finger before.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I bet.
Then at home,
yeah.
If you fall when you're a,
uh,
uhs fall,
a 30 centimeters.
Right?
Right.
Like Ghana,
but a over there it's a different thing.
You know,
you learn to surpass your fears and you would learn to calculate with your body
as a part of the calculation.
What was the scariest one of these stunts that you tried to attempt this
carriers?
What about the most exciting?
Most,
uh,
most of the fear because fear is just,
you know,
uh,
advising sickness within,
um,
which was the one,
maybe it swimming under the ice.
So I lost track lesson to this story.
This is nice.
Uh,
I had no goggles on.
Wow.
Why did I doubt dove like one meter thick ice.
So the ice is three feet tech for people to know what to meet her as you're
diving into the water.
And where is this in a Finland,
Finland.
Polar polar circle.
Insanely cold water.
It's a,
it's like a needles,
but I was trained,
I did not even feel the needles because that's one thing.
And then I did my breathing really good and this was the day before I was going
to do attempting to do,
I will rack up.
So I had to general reputation and there was nobody only one diver somewhere,
but he was not in the water.
And Ah,
ah,
to me I didn't want to just try and train half the distance.
I was like,
no,
if I have to do with tomorrow,
I'm going to do all the distance now.
But nobody to Curiel attention.
And nobody was so serious.
They only thought we are the safety around to real record with the television
and this and that and all that.
So I began to do this breathing,
which you just did.
And then at a certain point,
how are so light headed and this and that,
but then in the water in the cold and you become fully charged where?
To oxygen.
Okay.
So much that your Ph do elaborate.
Go really up there.
You feel lost.
Okay.
First you need to go under the ice and then you'll begin to swim a stroke by
stroke.
Every stroke is something more than a yard.
How far are you going under the eyes?
I,
I w w their length at that,
uh,
at the end that roca was about 60 yards.
So 60 yards holding your breath under the ice.
But in like 40 hours later I could not see anything anymore because my,
the rate enough froze.
Your retina froze.
Yes.
Ratana froze and I missed the whole at the 60 yards.
I was counting subconsciously.
I had it all figured out so much strokes.
That means I then I'll arrive at the,
at the other whole hot foreign.
Did you go blind?
Eh,
like,
uh,
like 70,
75 yards.
It's when I need to go back.
You'll only think they're very instinctively.
Yeah.
That moment,
there is no space for thinking.
And now when you say you went blind,
how much could you see Barry?
Blur,
blur,
Blur.
Yes.
So I went on swimming and trying to find a way to the hole,
but I never found it.
And I had actually in the distance I made the biggest,
this isn't ever that I could never reproduce this,
but doesn't matter.
The thing is I lost a fear of death.
Oh,
right over there.
It's like every animal in the wild dice,
you know,
at in peace one day die or not have an accident or this or that.
Um,
because the blood is alkaline,
Ph level is really up and the body is able to retreat in the nervous system,
then go into the central nervous system and then the terminal of the light and
that's it.
You go to sleep.
And I had the same sensation.
My Ph levels was so raw,
Rosen before I went in that there was never a lack of oxygen or the lack of
oxygen was there,
but it was never disturbing.
With the West drawable there's no panic of the entity.
It was absolutely no panic.
Actually I felt a little bit good,
you know,
like,
like a rush,
like going to sleep.
Wow.
So you thought somebody grabbed me death?
Yes.
So somebody grabbed you and said like two times I experienced this,
I lost my fear of death.
And that's a personal story.
I wouldn't try it under a,
you know,
buddy to water these breathing exercises you have to learn first to recondition
your body to its natural state and then you get a different connection.
You are more able and become more conscious of your abilities.
So someone grabbed you and brought you to the hole?
Yes.
To the 50 meter hole back as we knew it,
turned around and went backwards trying to find out where the hole was.
Yes,
there was more than one horse.
Hair whole was there.
I went that way.
So one was said,
I tried it right there.
They brought me back here.
Okay.
So I did more than doubled it.
So for people listening you,
you missed it by going to the right and then you went to the left and you
couldn't find it.
So there was a 50 meter hole.
And then what was the second hole?
70 meters?
No,
no,
no.
It just one 50 meter.
50 meter hill was just one whole.
Okay,
so you just just totally missed it.
Yeah.
And so then they brought you back to the whole,
yeah.
So you did accomplish what you set out to,
but you did it with while being blind?
Yeah.
I'm still be double the distance.
Did it mess with your vision at all permanently?
So when you got out of the water,
how long was it before he could see again?
Um,
almost directly.
Really.
Almost directly.
A blue state.
A little,
but that's what I began to feel as oxygen comes back,
uh,
it almost directly was restored again,
I'm,
one of the things that I found fascinating about the Cryo tank is say your
eyeballs don't get cold.
I took,
why does everything gets cold?
But my eyes don't get cold.
I've,
I've found that fascinating when I'm outside and I'm freezing cold too.
It's never the eyeball itself.
And I don't know if it's,
there's a lack of nerve endings are,
I don't know what it is.
We are not billed to swim under eyes,
but we are built to be able to walk like a in wits outside for hours and days
and maintain vision because that's survival.
Right.
But you can also get snow blind,
right?
Like with their white.
Yeah.
White somehow or another the reflection off the white.
That's the different story.
Yes.
Yeah.
With her.
What I like on Mount Everest,
on these mountains actually we are not billed to get up there now either.
I found out about to,
it's a amazing,
once I hit it.
And you did it in shorts.
Yes.
And that piss off the other people that are trying to climb Everest.
So did that piss off the other people that are trying to climb matters because
the tanks and I don't think it is a challenge to do.
We didn't close.
Yeah.
Anything I,
it's no challenge.
You are not in contact with the natural environment at that moment,
but well how come so many people dive.
It's not a challenge.
It seems like it's a big challenge and they just not prepare properly.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's a lack of oxygen over there and if he used all the time oxygen at a
certain point you don't use oxygen and you get in a storm or a blast or a
wideout to things,
so they knew I was just lost.
Yeah,
I simply lost the up there.
It's a different laws.
Now listen,
I am going for the fourth time now climbing Kilimanjaro in Eh,
in,
in January coming and he and I teach people to do it in a record time without
mountainy or experience and even having you know,
diseases like Roma or asthma or chronic diseases,
things like that.
In four months,
four days.
Actually one day in one month I trained them and then they have to do say
exercising at home and believing which I would just be in it and no,
no ego.
We go,
I always tell and then in four months the oldest participant without
mountaineering experience is 76 years old and we are going to do it in a record
time.
That's learning how to use,
if you know how to use the adaptive power of ours and you uh,
endorse it with a ride,
breathing and believe the believe was the neurotransmitters who are influencing
on some level the breathing brings about the right Ph level.
And then uh,
and then the adaptive force is able to adapt to enter into the body because the
chemistry is right.
And when you say the right Ph levels,
is it something that's been measured?
The difference in the Ph level?
Yes.
We just completed a new studies and the Chiro,
uh,
that all the people who are doing this,
they had uh,
Ph level average of 7.8 and then went down to the normal,
a real natural standard,
which is 7.3,
7.4,
eh.
But most of us we have lower and more aesthetic,
steady state levels of a Ph decrease.
And we did a research on pain.
Now if you get a few are able to control to 7.6 Ph level,
you are able to control the pain signal.
It falls apart.
Try Mary's [inaudible] try mayor is the three components.
And if you bring up the Ph level controlled to 7.6,
it falls apart.
You don't feel the pain anymore.
And we lost the ability to suppress or control the pain.
Now with this breathing,
influencing on the Ph level,
uh,
consciously,
you're able to come to learn to control the pain.
We just finished a studies and a hundred percent school once again.
Wow.
Now this Mount Kilimanjaro thing,
is this the first time you've ever led a group of people say a third time
already?
Would you like anything else to drink
more coffee or anything?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Let's get a get a few beers.
Oh yeah.
Oh boy.
Here we go.
Yeah,
sure man.
So this Mount Kilimanjaro thing you are,
you're going to take these people know,
do you have any concern or taking a 76 year old person without any understanding
of their physical condition?
Do you going to give them a thorough examination or have someone do that or what
do you,
how are you going to approach the,
you know,
after 30 years or 35 years,
almost five 40 years already.
Uh,
you know,
experience of exposing buddy the physiology to extremes.
I know,
and I can feel if I'm fit or somebody is able or fit to do,
uh,
being part of a calculation in the extreme.
I learned to climb without gear on blogs.
That means you read the rock first and then you are part of the calculation and
add a Sam Adams in there.
Okay.
Good Solos to Eh,
have nausea,
man.
Yeah.
Have a Heineken.
Let's see.
From your people right now.
That's,
that's German,
right?
Isn't it?
Boston.
Oh,
is that a Boston yesterday?
It wasn't Boston past.
And they say about Chicago and the other one.
Yeah.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
So it's Heineken.
Heineken.
What does that start from Germany?
[inaudible] isn't that from as to how to staff your people?
Yeah.
People,
yeah.
People have,
uh,
accomplished some incredible things.
Holland is the birthplace,
the birthplace,
but one of the greatest star kickboxing nations in the world.
Yeah,
yeah.
My training.
Oh,
Allister over.
I want to talk about that.
So what are you doing for Alster?
The same my data with you and get into you.
Yeah.
You know,
if you do cheers.
Yeah.
Cheers man.
All right.
So,
um,
so with Allister,
how did,
I asked her,
found out about it,
find out about you and how did this get started?
Alice data is absolutely not stupid,
is a very controlling and intelligent person.
Yeah.
It's very smart guy kick calculating what he is doing and he's trying to get
always the best out of it.
So he came to me,
uh,
because of people saying,
Hey,
this guy is scientifically endorsed.
He got some methods about breathing and focus and it's all been measured.
So he asked me,
uh,
to come by.
He came by and this is in Holland?
In Holland.
In Amsterdam.
Where does beer come from?
Two chairs.
And we just had,
we had a talk and uh,
demand is so in control of his body.
He can,
he can read my mind when he's talking with me,
if I'm being right,
because he can feel what happens with his logic and his body.
So he thought it to be right and okay.
And then he is,
he's listening.
He's a pupil.
He's very humble.
He's a nice guy.
That's all.
And uh,
he has learning,
listening,
respecting.
Okay.
And Danny took it up.
I told him what to do.
I told him,
you have to regain the connection with the hormonal system.
You know,
when you fight,
you try everything and your hormonal system gets out of balance.
Sort of is possible from Strauss.
Yeah.
From stress meaning a,
yeah.
And those people live in their extremes.
So,
eh,
your mono system gets out of control and uh,
we bring it back first and Youdo you know what you want,
you want to win,
but more of it,
you want to have control with it and you want to feel that you are able to stare
and to direct your body.
And in the training you want to get better.
But if you frustrate yourself,
then it's because of hormonal disbalance and a training,
training,
training.
But it doesn't get through.
And what we do is just taking away the blockages and the balance.
The disbalance balance does,
you got to open way because you want to win,
you want to increase,
you want to become better and you know you're feeling
and then take up with cold water.
I told him and uh,
the,
uh,
easy does it you in a bit.
You begin with cold showers,
that's hill and now he's taking cold baths,
you know,
ice bath every day and it's two weeks later he told me,
uh,
he is improving so much that,
that you regained the connection with his,
uh,
deeper physiological systems.
The,
and the green and the,
and the immune immune system as well.
But he is healthy already.
But the systems that's important for him because you know,
it's pure adrenaline.
What happens,
right when you do a match,
but you're living to word it.
I learned,
I've learned how to deal with the mind.
I explained about the mind as well.
And now two weeks later I got a phone.
He told me,
I'm going to win.
Why?
Because I feel I've taking charge.
I'm in charge with my own body and I'm not talking,
uh,
you know,
bigger.
Alistair Overeem is his person.
I don't know the way he is now,
but I'm going to meet him say next week and do a lost training directing simply
awakening his ability.
Like everybody,
Eh,
the ability to connect with a deeper physiological systems within our body,
enabling us to do anything because this adaptive power is really so far out.
It will for fighters,
that can be a huge advantage because one of the big things that happened to them
during hard training is their endocrine system starts to break down.
Their testosterone levels are very,
very low during training camps because they're oftentimes overtraining,
meaning their body can't recover and they're training so hard.
My body doesn't have enough time to recover.
You think that you can stimulate the production of testosterone?
Yeah.
In people's
bodies.
Oh yes.
You know,
Eh,
W W eh.
Think logically testosterone is about program creation and all that,
you know,
all right,
and the fans of your territory.
It's a natural thing.
But if you keep on training,
training,
then the body shuts down because there is no meat to the fence.
You are looking for some imaginary opponent.
That's what the nature of this and the endocrine system is telling you.
So you have to learn to control this primitive reactive part of ours.
It's a primitive brain,
the brainstem and learn to bring it under your dominion.
And as we are,
uh,
if you take on too much adrenaline,
then it becomes acidic and you mess up the endocrine systems.
Very logic.
Now we have shown that without,
for us,
we are able to produce more adrenaline than somebody in a,
in a,
a low going into a bungee jump,
you know,
very fearful.
Allow.
Do you do that?
Like you were,
you were saying that earlier,
like if someone's lying and what did you do?
The breathing method.
Exactly.
But do you have them visualize something terrifying or no at once again,
if I,
if I want my bear,
I'm not grabbing this telephone.
Right.
And they're not an either this right.
Nowadays,
you know,
I just be busy with what you,
what you are aiming at.
Okay.
That's it.
And visualization comes from itself.
You know,
you see a mountain and you feel I want to climb this,
then it'll be there every time you are there and tuning the body to work the,
the eventual performance.
Uh,
and this is the way it is done inside.
And sometimes you can,
you know,
visualize first and then I say,
well,
I'm breathing a badger knows by this.
I dare say that.
Oh,
it doesn't matter what kind of hole you use,
just make it happen.
But how do you stimulate adrenaline though?
Like if you have someone lie in the back,
like if you have me lie on my back and I'm starting to do your breathing
exercises.
Gotcha.
You know what we do?
Okay.
A day.
So odd in the university
they saw,
they got,
they got these devices to measure the saturation of oxygen in the blood.
And normally at sea level,
like here,
it's like 100%,
but this is only the measurement device.
They created it and it goes from a hundred percent to 30% 30% everybody's dad,
something like that.
At 40 50.
Normally the people die.
So they have these measurements.
They measured us,
no,
the guys I e trade and they saw,
uh,
not only a hundred percent,
but probably 150% but the measurement device is wrong.
It's just based on what we think that our body is capable of.
I put this aside,
we do this breathing exercise.
Then you see it directly on the monitors.
What happens if you're,
uh,
are without,
eh in the lungs staying without air in the lungs like you did two and a half
minutes.
What happens?
Everybody after one and a half minute,
got to do this a hundred percent on the device,
on the Monitor,
probably 150,
but it was only visual,
really showing and invisible after one and a half minute that the a hundred
percent was rich.
Then went into 90,
30 measurement device shuts down,
Bang,
we go even lower.
And then a buddy,
eh,
the primitive bearer brain in the brainstem,
the reptilian brain who only reaction cold,
like reptilian called warm deprivation of air,
things like that,
you know,
very primitive.
We got a Po,
the brainstem of ours works like that.
It react.
So at that moment it doesn't think,
Eh,
uh,
there is no oxygen.
No,
I just reacts because there is no oxygen inside the body.
But because the Ph levels we went,
uh,
have been resined,
nothing is happening to the body.
We at the primitive brain is reacting the,
the,
the brainstem and it gets into this survival mode.
And so much that that adrenaline wow is over there.
So it's just about holding the breath for long periods of time.
While you were symbolism,
I will sample as well.
And that causes a dry well,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that,
that way,
without any damage in the brain or nothing like that,
it also begins to,
if you do to on a regular basis,
it begins to,
uh,
reestablish neuro patterns between the Neocortex,
the,
the surface of the brain,
our thinking,
and the primitive brain.
Does that make sense?
Because when you had me hold my breath and I only did it for two minutes,
but I was starting to panic.
I was like,
my body was going,
what are you doing dude?
What are you doing?
Come on,
breathe,
bitch.
My body was telling me,
come on,
breathe,
breathe.
Hey Joe Rogan isn't bitch.
I call myself a bitch all the time.
It's my secret.
My secret is I'm a fan.
He's a bitch.
My secret is I'm never impressed by me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Me Too.
Now this Mount Kilimanjaro thing,
um,
I want to get back to that because that to me what's dangerous about that is not
you.
Because I think that you have a very deep understanding of who you are and what
you're capable of.
And obviously you've done amazing things,
but these other people,
how do you know them?
Do you know how,
how well
you know them and how you love that
feeling as understanding.
Right.
And we have the ability like living in a a,
you know what a pack of wolves.
No,
we are mammals.
Stool and a pack of people.
We are able to exist in nature and as I know the challenges in nature and how to
counteract it with the interaction with the nature.
I know how to lead people through uh,
extreme in extreme conditions and already did it twice.
First of all,
26 people.
The oldest one was 65 people without mountaineering experience and with four
bypasses,
coronary by 65 years old and coronary artery bypass us.
And uh,
a guy with cancer,
two people with the disease of chrome,
one went to Roma Arthritis,
[inaudible] Roma,
Roma,
Roma Arthritis,
arthritis,
atrocious.
You haven't had all kinds and uh,
outer immune diseases and we had a lot of them.
Ms Multiple Sclerosis for example.
Yes,
you've been able to help those people improve their conditions and are not only
26 people and we told them at a,
in the press,
we are going to climb the Kilimanjaro in three days in shorts and everybody's
saying,
but in this condition,
without mountainy arena experience,
people are going to die.
The physiology states that this is not possible.
Right.
Many,
many,
many arguments.
And then we didn't do it in three days.
We did it in two days.
Oh my God.
And they change these guys.
They have a lot more control within their lives and they know from within.
Then last year,
oh this year or January we did it once again over and we did it.
We took 16 hours off from the two days from the 46 hours where two 31 48 hours
to 31 hours and this time the oldest man is 76.
I can feel it if one is able to do with it,
it's him.
And then I have still have to see about the youngsters because their mind is yet
not so in connection with the body.
That's that you say that because ultra marathons,
um,
are typically run by older people.
It's one of the more interesting aspects of that endurance sport is brain body
connection.
They,
they're also tougher.
Yes.
And a no.
I would like to Bush man [inaudible] they haunt a kudu like for two days and the
Kudos
and they just persistence training.
Ah,
that's us.
We do conscious breathing and this conscious breathing is a neural pattern
between the body and mind and the animal hasn't got it.
Well,
the animals also not physiologically cable running long distances,
like a person who is they?
They,
they tire out there.
They're built for sprints and that's what they do.
They just wear them out.
They persistent tent.
They chase him down and they wear him out.
But oftentimes they're too exhausted at the end of it to even enjoy it.
Yes,
yes.
Bye.
Okay.
I,
but it shows once again,
the mind,
the mind and the breathing because the breathing,
when people get a headache,
which is the first sign of a acclimatization problems,
a high altitude disease and a mass acute mountain sickness is what it is,
then I just make them breathe and bring more oxygen to the brain.
So if you're,
if you're climbing up,
you're not using any of those oxygen tanks,
and a lot of those people use not thinking.
And when you hear about people dying up there,
do you think that you could have helped those people if you taught them?
Oh yeah,
I'm techniques.
Oh,
yes,
yes.
Oh,
absolutely.
I saw all the,
you know,
26 people ranging from 22 to 65 with coronary problems with,
uh,
all these diseases and still able to do within two days in shorts.
That means all in shorts.
All in short,
76 year old guys in shorts.
Yes,
yes.
And women.
Yeah.
Not,
not only in shorts.
Uh,
wow.
But it happens,
you know,
and it's possible people transform,
people get back to their natural ability.
That's it.
Wow.
That's,
um,
that's a big responsibility to take a group of people like that and to,
to be,
you understand?
Yeah.
It is a big responsibility,
but I'm so sure because I trust nature.
[inaudible] so I just respond to what I feel naturally with these people.
But what if you get somebody with you that's a legitimate bitch?
Like what if someone signs up for it and they just,
it just fold under pressure.
There are people like that,
that do that.
Yeah,
I know.
I know what you mean.
I say ego,
no ego.
We go like before,
right.
And this is that.
And I got a very good sense of control on and detecting if somebody is hiding
something.
Because if you hide something and you have an attitude on the mountain,
the mountain is much stronger than you that is going to break you.
And you think that would be part of that would be a big issue with the attitude
of the person.
Yes,
yes.
It will,
will uh,
horrify the person said to ration and then it's not in a way he will,
uh,
he will block us of going up,
you know,
and get a rate amount is just a problem but he won't be,
he or she won't be able to get up on the mountain anymore.
And you're saying an attitude meaning like a negative attitude or an attitude of
ego,
like the ego protecting you from giving in and,
and,
and if realizing your true potential,
right.
You have to learn to let go,
like in the cold as well.
You have to learn to let go.
Then things can happen in the body naturally and that you are able to manipulate
and they can absorb your mindset as well.
They can absorb your example.
And that's one of the things,
like I can tell just talking to you and being around you,
that you,
you have,
this is very powerful belief in what you're saying and what you're doing.
And when people around you and they
fucking good bitch,
man,
we love live.
Well,
you know what I'm saying?
I love you too.
People absorb.
It's back when,
when people around someone like you that has this legitimate,
powerful belief in what you're saying and what you've proven to be true,
then other people absorb that.
And it's one,
it's a thing that if someone has an attitude,
meaning a negative attitude,
or they have too much ego,
they're gonna say,
wow,
who the fuck's this guy?
Well,
why does he think he knows this?
you know,
you know what I've done when we tell you what I've done,
you know that type of person is going to fall apart,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I always blocks the hoc nature is my teacher and he is merciless but righteous.
Mm.
Yeah.
Merciless.
But righteous is true.
You know what is possible?
Because you have achieved it and they know that you know this truly,
you know,
there are,
there are people you know,
uh,
in taekwondo that the teacher is a called a Saba Nim.
You know,
like Sensei and karate is Sabam Nim is the Korean version of it.
And what that means,
the literal translation is one who leads by example.
And so,
but you leading by this example,
you,
you doing this and showing these people that this is all possible.
Yes.
They absorb that when you,
that's one of the reasons why it's so important to be around and we got notified
nor very people.
Yeah.
When you're around them,
you take that in,
who take that hit.
And when you're around people who are troubled and were falling apart and
failing at everything,
you take that into and it's bad for you.
You know,
when you could,
you could be around people that are always in trouble and your life will be
affected by their negativity.
Yes.
So when you take these people with you,
you are raising them up with your own mind,
with your own,
your own belief in what you have done and what they can do.
You make them better.
Yes sir.
It is.
That way we shoot,
heal each other again.
Yeah.
And we can,
we can get everybody does their own part.
Yes.
If everybody gets in that fucking water,
don't be scared and not water.
Do you think that cold water is maybe even better than like a cryo chamber
because it's so hard to breathe in cold water?
You know,
when I was hosting a fear factor,
one of the hardest things that we had people do was cold water stunts because,
uh,
you're,
if you're,
especially if you're not used to it,
one,
I mean,
I jumped in cold water before.
One of the craziest feelings is you can't breathe.
Like when you get in the water,
you body,
it was,
it's like this weird thing where you bought,
you can't,
even if your head is above water,
like if I get in a pool,
okay.
Like a normal pool,
like a swimming pool.
Um,
I am,
it's nice.
I can breathe.
I breathe just like I can right now.
But if you get in cold water,
even if you're up to the same level,
your head is above water,
you can't breathe.
It constricts your body's ability to take in oxygen.
You're like,
Ooh,
Ooh.
Do you think then in that sense that maybe there's more benefit even to getting
in a tub of ice and water than there isn't one of those cryo chambers?
I think so,
yes.
Yeah.
You see it longer too,
right?
Yes.
A USC had a difficulty with a cold water.
You see,
and as you see it,
that means that it needs a greater performance and greater control over the body
to do that.
Yeah.
But then why don't you do this consciously?
You get a bigger control over your body and you are able to perform better.
And it's a avascular thing.
I can explain,
but it takes quite some time.
So maybe it's like the,
maybe the smart thing to do is to do both things is do like a cryo chamber for
the physical effects because they say that the cytokines are released in the
body.
When you get to like 150 degrees below zero,
like that's like the most benefit where your body produces the most anti
inflammatory reaction.
You don't get that cold when you get in the ice bath with water and the ice
doesn't get to 250 degrees below zero.
But maybe that there's more benefit with the mind and with controlling the
breathing in that respect because you have to breathe in deeper longer and you
can sit in an ice bath for 20 minutes as opposed to the three minutes of the,
like when I've,
when I've taken people into the Cryo therapy place,
you know,
they say,
I don't think I could do it.
I'm like,
well,
the first time you do it,
you're going to do it for 22 for two minutes.
You count to 60 twice and it's over.
Just go one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
So you do that.
You're,
you're one 10th of the ways there.
He can't to six you one 10th of the way to 60 can do it 10 times.
You get to 60,
do it again and you're done.
It's over.
It's two minutes is nothing.
You can hold your breath for two minutes.
It's not that hard.
But ice bath is a different story.
Again,
that ice bath you into that thing
and it's all half eyes,
half water use.
That's when you really have to,
so this,
but you can't,
for athletes,
you can't train after you do the ice bath after you the ice bath,
your body is so cold that they say you can't work out afterwards,
but you can work out after you do cryotherapy.
So maybe like the benefit for athletes is dual combination of the two things.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
Uh,
though,
when I get the,
I got these people going done with a cup and within a couple of hours you will
see that they are able to do so much more.
And that's that wakening the right Ph levels.
Once again,
controlling it by breathing and focus,
using focus.
And then,
uh,
having a lot more control over the chemistry and the chemistry is needed,
controlled when you get the impact of the cold,
which is a force,
you need to produce a cat,
a chemically,
a within your own body,
consciously a contract force,
a,
uh,
opposing force.
And we are quite able to do that.
But you have to know how to do that,
that,
uh,
and for every individual is a little bit different.
So for tuning like,
so,
uh,
yeah,
it's a vascular thing,
Eh,
USA,
uh,
we are able to go like 20 minutes,
in a,
in a cold ice bath eventually,
but not in a cryo therapy.
I've had a political,
uh,
chamber and that's because it works different on the body and Eh,
it works on the marrow,
it gets deeper insight.
It's a dry,
it's dry and you know,
water gets 25 times faster into the body.
It's a different force.
And A,
I recommend myself,
I don't know exactly,
but I would recommend the ice bath beyond cryotherapy.
Cryotherapy is,
you know,
very artificial union.
You need a tank,
you know it is and people are not able to get into it.
But when you get a means,
I cry therapists.
Okay.
I always had cold.
The cold is okay,
but there needs to be so much more research.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
There needs to be more research,
so much more research and once again,
I want to be beyond speculation,
but we are able,
and that's my belief.
Like 25 years ago I told everybody,
Eh,
the automatic nervous system in relationship to the immune system can be
influenced far deeper and they mocked me then and now it's science and they
changed the books and now I tell everybody,
listen,
up held strength.
Happiness is ours.
That's our natural
state and whatever we'll use therein cold or heat or stress or this or that,
which has an impact on the body,
we are able to withstand it or able to control it as we are able to control the
system,
which is our producing happiness,
strength and health will.
Your story,
most amazing aspects of it is your story is a story of persistence and a belief
because you've been doing this for a long time,
but it's not until recently that you've sort of broken through to the
mainstream.
I think vice has a lot to do with that.
That advice piece was so powerful.
Thanks.
Vice Vice Shane Smith,
my man.
Yeah,
right on.
When you,
um,
when you watch that piece,
it's undeniable because you're seeing you do these things and you're,
you're,
you're watching your enthusiasm and your belief.
You're taking these other people,
those reporters that were with you through this,
uh,
these experiments in these,
these techniques.
It,
it's got to feel good for you to finally be able to get this word out and to,
to realize that the light is at the end of the tunnel and that you've,
you've sort of reached this place where you're,
your ideas have gone viral.
Yes.
Eh?
Recognition.
Do you know Kelly Star?
It is.
He's a famous strength and conditioning coach and he's the author of the supple
leopard becoming the sub.
A leopard is a very,
very respected strength and conditioning coach.
When he found out that I was going to,
I didn't even talk to him,
but he found out through the grapevine that you were going to be on my podcast
and he sent me a text message and a a paraphrase it,
but he said that what your work is some of the most important work that's being
done today in the world of understanding the human body.
That's what he was saying.
He was saying that you,
what you're doing right now for,
for athletes and for people that want to understand how their body works is some
of the most important shit that's being happening right now and that four for
self empowerment for,
for this book.
I mean that's got to feel good for you.
It does it.
I mean what is the way I like to to to realize that from the time he was 17
having this calling to jump in the cold water,
do getting this understanding of what that really means to this breathing
method.
You're the developing and then having this scientific proof like this,
this,
this justification.
This elaborate testing that was done on you that shows that your,
your method has been,
it's been proven.
It's effective.
It's real.
It's written down.
It's undeniable
emotionally.
I know how deep can you go if you loose your wife at teatro but eh,
Eh,
it,
it has been healed and it's one of my songs to,
and I think now I've scientifically proven it.
Recognition as calm,
the mockery I stopped.
Respect is regained,
reestablished and that's good.
But there is still so much work to do because the love and the care for the
planet,
for the children,
for all living beings still is not established.
We got to change the mind and we got to go on now.
I don't want anybody to suffer anymore from and not being happy or not having
strength or not being healthy and uh,
and bring back to harmony until that we need to go on.
But,
um,
I'm really thankful for people like yourself and,
uh,
this person Telia Keller.
Yup.
Kelly,
thank you very much for,
for uh,
endorsing this.
We are going on and a Harvard is coming in and uh,
which is one of the best universities of the world.
And we will undeniably proof that we are able to become strong,
healthy and happy.
Everybody.
Would it start,
what does Harvard want to do?
What are their,
I don't know yet,
but you know the same person you were talking about the Rhonda and Rhonda.
Who is Patrick?
Yeah,
exactly.
Uh,
Rhonda,
Patrick,
she was with me two weeks ago,
one and a half week in Amsterdam or in a,
in the Netherlands.
My place.
We had a great,
great discussion.
Later she looked it up and compare the blood results with uh,
the threat number one in America,
which is uh,
uh,
arterial sclerosis.
It's the heart disease.
Anything what goes with the arteries and the veins and all that and that our,
uh,
alkalosis,
Eh,
within our,
uh,
within this technique is a,
is a capable of influencing in the arterial sclerosis.
Not Little bit pick time,
it's chemistry.
So we got it not only for the public enemy,
number one,
killing so many people in us.
It's all over the western world.
We got it all to for depression and we got it all.
So for any actually any disease,
we got to bring back the belief that we are beings who naturally should be
happy,
strong and healthy.
And as long as there are systems or this or complications and nobody knows
anymore how to be happy and without war and without tensions and too much
grieving and too much greed and all that,
then then we got work to do because the new world is a world of harmony and we
are working on this and we do this together.
I love the fact that you believe that and I think that it is possible.
And I really do.
I mean,
I've been called a chink,
my brother.
Yes.
I think,
uh,
we,
we live in a unique time because we can share information now in a,
in a way that was never possible just a decade ago.
And like something like this,
a podcast,
it's free and it goes out instantly and then the world gets it.
You know what in this information gets shared and transferred and everybody gets
a hold of it.
And then it reshapes the way people think.
And the,
the millions of people that will listen
to this,
it will absolutely affect their lives.
And how many of them will act on it.
You know,
it's up to them but it,
but it is possible and it will become viral because of that.
You know,
your ideas are becoming viral.
Yes.
And it's a non duct madec choice.
We gave the people no religion.
We give the people results,
no speculation.
If you do this,
then this happens.
And uh,
we want to bring back the natural state,
which is healthy,
strong and healthy.
Anybody could do this because it's endorsed with thousands of results and these
are the means you are helping,
Eh,
to make a paradigm shift possible.
So it's great work what you do and the world needs it and somebody needs to do
it.
So we do this together.
I told that this is good,
is very good,
but the beautiful thing about what I'm,
it's not really work.
I was just having a conversation with a cool guy.
Yeah,
that's a beautiful thing.
Likewise.
Now do you monitor your diet at all?
Do you,
are you conscious about what kind of foods you eat?
Are you,
do you have a specific diet that you follow?
They messed up a food really good,
Eh,
they synthesize that and a volume nice.
That and they make it really shiny.
You know,
if you take a paprika you can always,
you don't need a mirror.
Right?
Eh,
but the nutrients that they're in,
they are changed.
You know,
it was maybe half or less than the half of the nutrients,
which normally should be in there.
And vegetables.
You mean vegetable?
More durable and,
yes,
and a and a and also with the meat and a and all that.
So my,
my diet is,
uh,
is more vegetarian and I eat once a day,
once a day,
off to sex or after sex after six.
So you haven't had anything to eat?
No.
Yeah,
after 35 years.
Today I had my breakfast.
I have,
I have at breakfast,
but it's because of the jet lag.
And so what time is it now in Holland and highlight this like at nine hours
difference.
And I know ahead,
I had,
oh yeah.
Well,
that's,
that makes sense.
It's midnight takes energy and Becca,
but because I have this control over the,
uh,
the endocrine systems,
the Melatonin and Serotonin,
which is the day and the night,
I did not suffer any jet lag,
but still it takes energy.
You don't suffer jet lag when you fly.
No,
no,
no.
That,
that's a,
you know,
hormones,
you,
um,
by doing your breathing method,
you can sort of mitigate that.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
So I have a rule that I follow whenever I go anywhere that I might get jet lag,
which really far,
I go immediately to the gym is the first thing that I do and the less I'm
exhausted,
it's to regain strength.
But I've,
I exert myself in a very,
very way.
I don't do a light workout.
I do a ferocious workout when I land and I usually reset to me.
Yeah.
I'm just talking because if you do a ferocious workouts,
you get into the adrenaline access,
uh,
of yourself as well by two.
A lot of people might think it's silly,
but I do a lot of things when I work out.
One of the things that I do is I,
I work myself into this state that where I feel like what I'm doing is I'm
fighting for my life.
I mean,
it might sound crazy,
but I,
I put myself out to the ocean.
Yeah.
If I lift weights or if I run on a elliptical machine or one of those things,
do a,
some sort of a cardiovascular,
I do it like I'm fighting for my life.
And I feel like that's,
that's the way I know that get the maximum benefits of it.
And now listening to you,
it makes sense why I'm doing this.
Like I just been doing this sort of instinctively because I feel like over the
years of exercising,
that's the way I've gotten the best results.
But people,
they,
let's say,
what the fuck you doing?
You're not fighting for your life.
Like I know I'm not,
but in my mind I am,
when I do it,
um,
I'm,
I'm 100% committed to it because my survival depends on it.
You are literally,
we're fighting for your life when you do extreme.
So like I do.
And,
uh,
I,
you know it and you are very focused at that moment that you have to go beyond
your conditioning.
You're not playing,
you're not pretending you and you're under the ice.
You are fighting for your life and you know a chat like something out of your
conditioning it with a,
if you are conditioned,
you are not able to surpass the effects of a,
of a jet lag.
But if you are able to get out of the conditioning,
go through it all,
then you are able to regain contact with the Serotonin and Melatonin balance
within the body.
And uh,
that's uh,
yeah,
overcome jet lag.
There is no jet lag.
So one meal a day in the evening.
And what like what's typically a meal for you?
Well,
I like pasta.
I'm sorry
that they say it's terrible at Teardra but I like macaroni.
It's delicious.
Yeah,
I'm Italian.
I enjoy it.
It tastes great.
I love it too.
I love it there.
My Pr.
So you eat a lot of pasta.
Well that's a lot of carbs.
You,
you burn off a lot of calories obviously.
If you're doing all this crazy physical stuff,
anything.
I can eat anything,
any amount.
Uh,
but I do it after six o'clock.
Why?
After six to when you wake up in the morning.
Is that you're not hungry or is it,
I don't want it to be stuffed.
I eat very lightly,
very lightly.
In the morning I eat.
My first meal is almost always fruit now.
That's mostly what I eat.
But that's not workout in the morning.
That's nice.
I have like a few pieces of fruit and I don't stuff myself.
I do it until I feel like I don't need any more.
She and I work out.
Sure.
And then afterwards I'll have something light.
Like today I had some Sushi,
very light,
you know,
not much.
Sounds great.
And then a dinner.
I usually eat a lot,
but I bet it's not about you.
It's about those people who are getting in so much.
Right.
It's not,
Eh,
they don't use it in the body anymore.
It's a thinking and too many calories and they have no control,
but it tastes good.
It says about it.
See for,
I think for a lot of people,
the problem is they go to a job that they don't really enjoy and they're stuck
in traffic and then they get to work and the reward is they'll have a donut,
they'll have some coffee,
they'll have a,
a break,
an egg sausage sandwich with cheese and mayonnaise we want,
but it's you're getting sensations when you're eating that that are pleasurable
and that's the reward and it's to take that a reward away from them.
You're,
you're,
you're giving them a few less bright spots and otherwise dull day.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Is what you call it.
And that,
so,
Eh,
the day's got to be dull.
We got to bring back the intensity of the wonder of the day.
And that comes with it being consciously connected with the depth of your
physiological systems and also comes with making good choices as to where you
are,
what you do for a living and how you spend your time.
Oh yes.
Wait,
we need to be creative.
All of us because creation and being creative is the expression of the soul and
the soul needs to breathe.
Like anything,
you know,
and,
uh,
it needs to expand in consciousness.
Yeah.
I've always had a real hard time with the expression creative people.
This guy's creative.
He's creative.
She's creative because people are all creative.
Everyone is creative.
It's just a matter of finding what it is that you're creative with.
Some people creative with the constructing cars.
Some people creative with clothing.
Oh yeah.
People are creative.
Like it's a part of being a human being.
It's not,
it's saying someone's a creative person.
It's like saying there are hard rock.
You know,
everyone,
every,
everybody's creative.
Yeah.
I did.
[inaudible] which goes along when people are creative.
It's beautiful.
It's,
it's,
it's a natural part of being a child.
Every child draws and paints and plays with things and sculpts and makes little
things.
It's a GNAT and it gets beaten out of us.
It gets beaten out of us in school,
beaten out of us with jobs and beaten out of us with responsibilities and
careers.
Paying Floyd.
Yeah.
A teacher.
Kids.
Hello.
Yeah.
No,
the brick in the wall.
Ah,
Shit.
My man.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
but for a lot of people,
they're like,
that's great,
but how do I get out of this?
And that's unfortunately,
that's your own path.
You've got to figure that out on your own.
But if,
if you can,
the problem,
if people also people get burdened down with bills and responsibilities and
debt,
credit card debt,
first of all,
they get you with student loan debt.
I don't know how it is in Holland.
Do you guys have a public universities?
Yes.
Yeah.
The same thing,
man.
That's her word.
There's a resistance to that in this country and it makes me sick.
School should be fucking free.
You know,
it should be frigging not making any money and we should encourage people to
learn as much as possible so that they could contribute more.
And I don't know how to do it,
but if I have to pay more taxes,
Jesus Christ,
I'll pay more taxes.
I think we should all be enthusiastic about people being able to get out of
school without being hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt.
I mean,
we have an enormous problem in this call.
We got a,
we don't have the same problem where is or without us.
We,
we,
we got a partial,
uh,
you know,
you got to redeposit the,
the,
the loan which you build up a something like that,
but,
um,
but it's much smaller.
It's smaller Italian spot.
It's yet,
it is not their solution.
Their solution should be that,
eh,
that the system is so complicated.
So,
uh,
away from us to begin to look,
people should be strong,
healthy and happy.
Are we able to do that?
And that's what we do scientifically right now.
And as he entered the day,
monster [inaudible] soon [inaudible] talk in rainy day.
It's,
it's a sort of a Latin and Churchill.
the science didn't prove it though.
There is more to prove and the school is not a way we should live for the life
is the school and in life we should be happy,
strong and healthy.
That's the way we are natural built.
So all the systems together,
right?
Yes,
yes.
It's,
it's quite large.
Heck,
very simple.
Very effective.
Very there.
And um,
yeah,
we just keep on making sense too.
We lost the sands.
Do you tell if it society has moved too fast for our bodies and that [inaudible]
this is all kind of tied together who you're talking about depression and you're
talking about how our body is not really designed to deal with the stress that
it deals with without any of the physical taxing of the,
the actual unit of the body itself.
You know,
the stress of exercise,
of exertion,
of a,
you know,
of dealing with the environment and Nicole,
all these things are sort of,
there's demands that are on the body and the same could be said about the
demands of society,
the demands of our culture,
the demands of civilization.
Do you think that maybe what's good,
what's happened is that our civilization has gotten too advanced too fast and
our bodies just have not be able to adapt.
So they're left in this state of confusion and anguish because they're trying to
get,
trying to get the there.
There's reward systems that are deeply ingrained in our DNA and they're not
being satisfied.
Exactly.
That's the neural connection between the neocortex and the and the brainstem.
The primitive part.
The,
the,
you know,
the human part of the thinking and the Reptilian,
the primitive brain,
the brainstem is,
it's cut off somehow.
And W that's why we don't control the stress of just stress,
which is stress hormone and a,
and the Korean system is connected to the brainstem and we lost this and it's
too much going on and we think the body will follow up,
but it is not following anymore.
We have problems and we,
what we are right now too is consciously bring back to neuro,
uh,
channeling between the neocortex with the brainstem.
And then I think it'll solve a,
it'll make sense again.
So exercise,
breathing,
diet,
all in consciousness,
mindfulness,
all these things are connected to live a happy life.
Yes.
Because happiness is about controlling the endocrine systems and they,
uh,
reciting it over there and that it needs a neural challenging.
What is the difference between the way you approach a cold environment versus
the way you approached what the,
what is the,
the thing that you did in the desert with no water?
Yeah.
I did it with a physiologist,
a doctor who was monitoring me and he saw eh,
without me having prior experience in the heat.
You didn't have any experience in the heat at all?
No.
It was w up into the,
where did you go and what did you do?
It not me and not me.
A desert.
Where's that as valet in the near a South Africa.
Uh,
and uh,
yeah,
I went down there and uh,
uh,
it's very dry desert by maybe the driest deserts in the world.
Maybe the second,
I don't know enough to have an impact on the physiology and I went up there and
I lost 5.2 liters of water.
Of Water.
Yeah.
You know,
things happening.
That's jugs.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's that's quite,
I ran a marathon.
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
it was 26 miles in that desert without drinking.
No drinking water.
No drink.
Did you rehydrate beforehand?
Did you like drink a shitload of water before you ran to coffee?
To Two cups of coffee?
I'm a little bit addicted to coffee.
I don't know if I'm going to master this.
Doesn't matter.
This is good,
but that's all know my mind was already there.
You know I'm going to do this and whatever w uh,
no extra water or anything like that.
And so you brought in physiologists to Ma to monitor your body what you're doing
this yes and that he saw all the range.
My core body temperature remained 37 degrees.
It's like Eno,
the normal body core that per but do I lost 5.2 liters of water.
So even an extreme conditions,
you are able to control the body and while you're running,
are you actively engaging in these breathing exercises while you're running?
I always say to the persons who would do endurance,
you know,
raw long distance rang could be a hundred kilometers or 100 miles,
500 miles.
They probably are knowing not probably they have to know to breathe more than
the normal air conditioned a breathing patterns which are shallow it because if
not breathing deep enough you will exhaust he reserves of oxygen in the tissue
and then the man with the hammer gums.
Yeah,
no you are not.
You become acidic.
You are not able to run anymore.
That's because the depletion of the oxygen in the tissue to is the expression
the man with the hammer comes.
Yes.
Yeah.
You're not able to do anything.
That's a crazy way to look at it though.
And then the man with the hammer comes.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I always say take one principal because we have the ability to store up my
oxygen,
but then you have to go past your condition breathing pattern,
which is too shallow and underperformance on the pressure.
It will just take the oxygen out of your tissue and then at a certain point it's
depleted and you are not able to run anyway,
but cozy ph levels become too low.
So you are able to influence in that pat,
uh,
in,
in that,
uh,
while you perform by thinking,
you know,
what thinking does,
influencing cell level,
but also breathe more than you feel is needed.
Oh,
okay.
A few running and you're like,
instead,
just big deep breath and just mess with your own buddy.
Daniel are able to get into the tissue and maintain in the,
in the cell biology,
oxygen instead off disconnecting and becoming acidic,
you oxygen is inside and gets on and is producing energy.
It's called Aerobic dissimilation.
It's a process in the cell.
But we are very able to do that.
And I do do it and I showed at people just in a couple of hours how to do it.
I stamp with people like,
eh,
even barefoot in the snow in short,
say on day two or three for one hour in the horse stance,
you know,
the horse dance and then stand for one hour in shorts and freezing temperatures,
barefooted for one hour in the snow in horse stance because they influence call
takes,
uh,
oxygen to combust energy.
Kabocha and it takes energy and it needs oxygen.
And uh,
and the horse stance is a performance is a pressure to it.
Heat it,
it creates heat.
It could create control.
It shows that we are able to influence sal biology by bringing consciously more,
uh,
oxygen inside,
thus producing more energy.
So how do you keep people from getting frostbite?
Because I would think that standing in the snow barefoot could make you get
frostbite after an hour.
They are still not,
not,
not suffering from frostbite and anything.
So high in day for us,
we begin to sing and we began to have fun and we're going on.
So I had,
I had these east European and Russian people coming to my place as well and they
look really tough and this and that.
And they have at this as a to you,
I say,
okay,
let's do an experiment.
If somebody is very tough at,
he just,
we take a bottle of water,
we put it in front of us,
we stand outside in the horse stance it barefooted and then uh,
in one hour or one half hours old alter.
Okay.
We drink all the butter and still remain in balance because the cold,
uh,
is affected.
Or if you get alcohol in,
uh,
in the blood.
So you need more oxygen,
unique mark on tour and we drink the whole bottle of vodka.
Oh,
drink vodka,
not water vodka.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think you said water.
I bought cat kind of comes from the word water is water.
So it looks like what Russians are
water,
same thing,
just drink
vodka in front of them.
They have to drink.
I say I do crazy experiments and I guess,
yeah man,
come on.
Life is crazy.
You got a crazy experiments under anybody's definition.
Life is crazy that we having fun and uh,
uh,
but we never did it.
Uh,
but uh,
I think,
Eh,
you know,
if you have a hangover,
a hangover,
you know,
then if you do 20 minutes this breathing,
then you have
no hangover anymore.
The uh,
it works that way.
You are learning to detox yourself in 20 minutes.
I have a,
a guy that I do podcasts with occasionally.
His name's Dr. Carl Hart and he's an addiction specialist and brilliant guy.
And he explained hangovers to me in a way that I never understood he could.
He's like,
we have this very confused sense of what addiction is.
And he said,
what a hangover is,
is your body being addicted to alcohol.
Even from one binge session,
your body creates these mitigating responses to the alcohol.
And then when the alcohol is no longer present,
you body has this like horrible headache and route it is,
is a compensatory response to the alcohol.
That's what it is.
Amazing.
Adaptive.
Yeah.
I mean that's what a hand like he redefines the premise of addiction and he
believes that are our ideas of addiction are very self limiting.
Yes.
So,
so we have very self limiting ideas about every hour control over life
itself.
Yes.
And then your breathing method just flushes this,
this yes.
Out of the system.
Yeah.
Any sense?
What are the athletes have you worked with other than Allister?
Um,
uh,
Olympic,
sports,
uh,
sports like rowing people,
people who doing a robot.
You do judo.
Uh,
so very Roebuck,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
yeah.
It's k this
a hockey team.
I'm going and when did these people start coming to you?
Yeah.
Well whenever I had this scientifically endorsed a result,
this one,
people began to think,
hey man,
this is,
this is real.
People think when it is scientifically proved,
then something is real.
No.
How do you have the time to engage all these people?
I mean,
it seems like you've got a lot of people pulling on your your time now,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
it does.
But once again,
I got my mission.
My mission is to help as much as children in the world as possible.
We have to bring back care and love.
And this is my mission and I,
I'm,
I believe in what I do.
So let the science come.
But to science as a,
as I see it sometimes is as fast as a slow toto,
they need to code very thorough.
The problem is your legitimate 100% but a lot of people are not
a lot of people on this podcast that I thought were legit.
And then after talking to them and then after going over their stuff and then
after being in contact with people have criticized their work.
You realize they're bullshit artists.
It did just really good at being a bullshit artist and they miss some of this
stuff they say is true self.
It is,
it is.
Unfortunately those people,
they bullshit themselves as well.
That's one of the fascinating things about bullshit artists is there their own
victim.
They're the victim of their work.
And you know what a guy like you,
it's frustrating to you because you are legit and you want this message to get
out there like that.
That scientific method is critical because that scientific method is also
establishing the,
the veracity of your work is establishing that absolutely what you're doing is
provable and it's real.
It's one of the things that makes you so unique is the fact that it's not just
you and your method is not just anecdotal evidence is the fact that there's a
bunch of people out there that have actually tested you,
that have no vested interest whatsoever and you being accurate.
And in fact,
we'd probably like to debunk you just as much as they would like to prove you
accurate and they can't.
And that's what things get very,
very,
very interesting.
And what's fascinating to me is that you're this one guy,
you're like an outlier in the most extreme sense of the term because there's 7
billion people and this one guy has figured some shit out.
What if you weren't around,
man?
What have you didn't exist?
We might never figure this shit out.
It might be a hundred years for somebody figured it out.
You know,
it makes you wonder like what,
what and now,
now we work together.
Yes,
I do know all the love you.
I love your work.
I love your spirit.
No,
I love the spirit.
That's why I love you.
You know,
for what we do and it needs to be done.
Somebody needs to do it.
And if we do it together,
we have stronger.
Well listen,
I'd love you to,
and I love your spirit and I love what you're doing and I will help you in any
way I can.
I will get this word out as much as possible.
I believe what you're doing,
man.
I think what's fascinating is that the parlor tricks as it were,
or your feets,
you're amazing endurance feats,
those,
that's what's bringing people to you.
You know the,
the,
when you see you on Everest and you shorts,
you know,
like,
uh,
there's this one image of you out in the snow and a,
you're bouncing on some ice.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like look,
that gets people going.
What the fuck is this guy doing?
And then they start researching it and then they started realizing like,
Whoa,
this guy,
this,
there's been scientific examinations of his claims and it holds up.
Like,
here's this is one image of you here.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Great Basher man.
You hope people see shit like that.
They go,
what the fuck is this crazy guy doing?
He's got no shorts on.
He's out in the snow.
It's freezing cold out and he's having a great time.
It's,
it's,
it's very contagious in a lot of ways.
I have a great time and it seems like what's going on here?
What is in this picture here?
This is Columbia sports wear.
This is a commercial.
Oh,
it's a commercial they did for it.
Yeah.
They did it at it though.
Uh,
that's,
uh,
that,
that sound a mum blah.
And then,
and uh,
the,
the Indiana Alps.
Wow.
And uh,
yeah,
more,
more stuff.
That's a crazy picture to see you out there in that frozen Tundra.
Yeah.
And your shorts,
Eh,
no church.
It's held out,
you know.
Well,
how about the one
when you're up there in the Lotus position?
Yeah,
that one.
What was that?
That's a Iceland,
Iceland.
Now how do you keep your legs from getting frostbite?
Like what,
what causes frostbite and how are you able to stop that from happening?
Yeah,
we got an ability to maintain,
uh,
above a zero within the cell biology.
And,
uh,
but as we not expose ourselves anymore,
we get frostbite,
etc. But if you get into the system and you learn to control a ride and you get
the right Ph degrees,
then eh,
the frostbite will not come because Eh,
we got the mechanism to do that,
uh,
that,
that will bring the cell temperature just above zero.
That means in a far now to what is 30 to 32.
And because if it gets below you get a rapper role,
a cell damage.
But yeah,
we,
uh,
mammals and we are able to do that like dogs and the cheaper,
well we do,
we know that people adapt to certain environments.
You know,
like they know that Inuits have a adapted,
uh,
a very interesting,
ability with their hands or their hands don't freeze up and get numb.
Whereas a person like me from California,
if I was in their environment,
I would have a real struggle.
But for them it comes natural and their body's adapted to this extremely harsh
environment.
It seems like human beings are much more pliable than we give them credit for.
That's the adaptive power which we have,
we are never resort to because we live in a conference,
a zone,
a kind of behavior,
and we think we can control nature.
But as long as we do not control what makes us happy,
strong and healthy,
we have no control at all.
And I want to bring it over there.
That's interesting.
So what we've been doing is trying to control nature.
We've been trying to build houses and heat them up and we've been trying to
control the environment instead of control ourselves to adapt to the
environment.
Exactly.
And it's nice to have a nice fireplace and everything a comment accommodated as
he'd rung.
But sometimes like a dog,
you need to go out and you know what else to the fireplace.
You don't appreciate that fireplace unless you're cold as fuck.
I really appreciate it when you're really begin to,
yeah.
Like after your eyeballs thought out,
like we were talking about going blind.
I bet if you've got in front of a fire then ah man,
it's,
man,
you're very silent than the Syrian at that moment.
And enjoying every bit.
We need the harsh to appreciate the mellow,
you know,
we,
we need,
we need hard things to appreciate soft things.
We need violence I think sometimes to appreciate piece.
Uh,
so there's something fascinating about human beings.
So we almost are designed to overcome and if we do not overcome,
we find that we find ourselves lost.
Yes.
And it's all about consciousness.
Yeah.
Being aware of live itself,
which is a wonder.
So we are going to bring it back first chemically.
And that make understandable,
that dinner,
you know,
consciousness and love are the best things on earth.
Accessible for everybody.
Now are you experiencing over like how,
what has been the last few years?
Like what has it been like where people are awakening themselves to your
accomplishments and your work and your,
your,
your belief?
What,
what has it been like?
It seems like at least me on the outside becoming more and more aware of you.
It's like I'm getting people tweet at me all the time with your videos and
articles about you and all these different people.
Ask me about getting you on.
It seems like there's an awakening and it's going on.
How much of a requirement has that been on your time and,
and you,
and what does that feel like to you to,
to have all these people sort of like a overwhelmingly coming after you now?
Yeah.
I love it.
But,
uh,
and I think this way and being with people like you,
like a Joe Rogan is a entity is not just you,
it's more to Amh.
We got to use and abuse all the,
as for the goal to bring it [inaudible] to any body.
And,
uh,
every person in the world,
we want to make the world happy.
We want to make it strong and healthy.
You know,
we want to bring consciousness of the wonders of life itself.
And as long as we,
uh,
as it is not there,
then these all these people who tweeted you and uh,
well helping me now,
that's where the way I feel it,
it's,
it's a of itself that brings me to wort,
uh,
this,
yeah,
this mission and the destination of it is helping children love and care.
I thank these people are very,
very much from the heart and we still need to go on.
So we all need you.
You,
you keep bringing it up.
Children.
That's a primary focus.
Is that because you feel like they're the most receptive to new ideas?
Exactly.
They are open and they have to learn from people who are wise.
You know,
we are,
we are the elders.
Somebody's got to do it.
And that's us.
So we have the responsibility and are we able to respond?
And that's right now,
right here.
That's why I'm here with you.
And you're asking,
and I can feel you are some,
you know,
you go deeper into,
uh,
at all.
None.
Yeah.
What is deeper than love?
What is deeper than the care for a child?
And that's what we need in once begins to establish the love continuously
without fear of disease,
without fear of being unhappy,
without fear of being,
having no energy,
etc. Then the love will bloom because that's the natural flower of every person.
And uh,
I,
yeah,
that's why I call it a children or it's he'd drive,
we have to make this body,
this beautiful,
beautiful planet,
which is actually best part in all the universe.
We don't need to look beyond Maurice or they're,
or they're,
or they're just look within and make this world a better place in harmony with
the nature.
And it begins with the children.
I share that idea and,
and I've been saying to people for a long time that one of the things that makes
me so enthusiastic and so optimistic about the future is the fact that we can
reach kids now in a way that we couldn't reach them before we could reach kids
with ideas and with open mindedness and with just massive amounts of information
that just weren't available before.
And that if you can change their opinion or inform them or,
or expose them to new ideas that generate new creative ideas inside them,
then you have broken the system and this system that's designed to carve paths
that have already been,
they've already been traveled.
And then,
you know,
I want to be a lawyer just like my dad.
And you get on that same fucking path and you get stuck.
And I think now there's,
there's an infinite number of paths and they're branching off into infinite
different directions and new streams and new new tributaries.
And I think we live in a beautiful time because of that.
Because a guy like you in Holland can get your ideas out.
You see,
I have to do a few things and then all of a sudden people know about it and then
it spreads.
And then you connect with other people and you connect to me and I connect to
the Internet and then it connects us.
And then there's going to be people that are practicing what you do and then
they're gonna tell their friends and it's going to get,
they're going to tweet about it on the write blogs about it,
and boom,
boom,
boom and make videos.
And then to overwhelming,
that'd becomes overwhelming.
And then it becomes a natural part of life.
Yes.
And it is overwhelming.
The wonder of life is overwhelming and uh,
media is helping us.
It is to Napa and all that.
This kind of media is the best because no one's controlling it.
You know,
the fact that anybody,
you could start your own podcast right now.
Dee is controlling.
You ever thought about starting a podcast?
No.
No chat.
I got this.
I got him to help me on the podcast.
You never did this.
Why didn't you get done?
Yeah.
Yep.
We'll talk to him.
Jay Jamiel school.
We'll,
we'll get this trait.
All right.
Um,
so beside the Harvard thing,
uh,
the studies,
what else do you have going on that people can look for it?
Ah,
well we get the unit different universities and uh,
we got different protocol to out,
uh,
to do,
work on,
uh,
arthritis,
arthritis and different auto immune diseases in general and uh,
about depression.
I want to get,
we are able to control the pressure.
Really.
That's amazing.
That's a huge,
huge,
huge problem.
Not just in this country,
but all over the world.
Yes.
The one of the main problems that plagues modern human beings.
And it's not so difficult.
It's very simple.
But yeah,
no,
the genius of things is to make things simple and that's,
believe we are built to be happy,
strong and healthy.
We just need to go back to nature,
a natural loss within us and uh,
and connect again.
Very simple.
Um,
is there anything that people should read that you've done or watch?
Is there any,
besides the vice documentary,
is there anything else that people that you recommend people check out?
You know,
I did this study,
which we did is actually the first study that showed that the autonomic nervous
system and relationship with the endocrine systems and immune systems are deeply
to be deeply,
uh,
able to be influenced.
So bacteria has no chance.
Things like that.
You know,
that's crazy because that's a,
that's also,
you know,
I had a friend of mine who got a staph infection,
the horrible staph infection.
I posted a photo of it online the other day because he got Murcia,
which has medication resistant staph infection.
It's horrific,
horrific Asia.
You should do this.
And you think that this,
something like this could help that.
I,
uh,
I think I'm sure about it,
but my,
my son,
my team is always say,
I don't tell you I killing people.
I teach
totally scientifically proved it was 25 years ago.
I stayed at something that is scientifically proved,
uh,
now,
and it changed his sirens as it is.
Well,
I think what they're doing is they're just,
they want to reign you in just because they not understand the importance of
what you're saying.
Yeah.
And that,
you know,
they're,
they're optimistic but cautiously optimistic.
It is.
So it is so,
but if I see the person and,
and always,
Eh,
they won't get worse of it at least.
And I saw miracles happening because live is a miracle.
I saw people getting back to life,
you know,
to,
to be in connection with life and trust within their own natural ability.
And then changing the old a day,
a disbalance this so much that they felt confident within their own buddies
again and taking away a half a regaining control over their immune systems.
And then diseases go and it's very simple.
You just need to do it.
I just need to activate those systems that are inherent in the body.
Exactly.
You know,
I just think guys like you,
you,
I mean,
I,
I want to say guys like you,
but I don't know anybody else like you.
But I think what we've done,
it's so amazing and so important because out of all these human beings,
all stuff that's going on,
all the different activities and interactions,
all the different thoughts just takes one person,
step out with a new unique idea that could be completely revolutionary and
change the way people behave and the way people interface with nature.
And I think you've done that and uh,
I thank you very much man.
Thank you for coming on here.
I really,
really appreciate it.
I love you.
I love your work.
Thank you and keep on and uh,
uh,
and we do it together.
Yes,
absolutely.
We are all on the same mission.
Bring back love and confidence that we are able to do,
you know,
to be a part of this wander.
Well,
anything you ever need tweeted or put on Facebook or put it on the podcast,
just let me know.
And you've got an open invitation to come back anytime you want.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
So thank you very much ladies and gentlemen.
And a you or your Twitter page is what is ice man?
What is it in a,
in a fire dot.
Darnell?
No,
the Twitter page is a,
it's actually ice man Hoff.
It's Iceman,
underscore,
h.
O.
F.
And uh,
that's the,
that's the Twitter page.
And a,
your website is a,
what is your website?
Your website is a
whim hub.
What does it waving?
Hoff method.com when hof method whim w I,
m h o f,
method.com.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it.
All right,
folks.
See you soon,
mother.
Only Mama.
Hmm?